[Music]
well hi everybody time for another
matinee show yeah new movie review
here's another one that we rented on
Xbox I believe it's also streaming on
some other services as well Amazon Prime
perhaps this is called inheritance yeah
surprisingly good I like this one I have
to tell you that it really does seem
like it's getting kind of like
lackluster reviews which I guess I can
see why but I actually kind of really
dug this movie it's like we were going
through and we were watching like
trailers for like all the new stuff like
whatever the new possibilities were and
I usually let Tom pick because I'm just
like well here's you know here's the
pool of ones we have to pick from and
then we'll go through and watch the
trailers need be like oh that looks the
best er that's the one that he's in the
mood for so we watched that one and he
thought the trailer for this one look
the best this actually it's not a horror
movie it's like a mystery thriller type
movie um and basically you know
obviously this just came out it was
supposed to come out like I think it was
posed to come out at a festival like in
April but because of the you know
pandemic and everything it got delayed
so it ended up this really just came out
on streaming like one or two weeks ago
so this is like actually really really
new um I'd like I said so I don't want
to spoil it but I might spoil like the
thing that the trailer spoiled you know
what I'm saying but if you really don't
want to know anything anything about
this movie then you should probably like
watch it before you watch the review you
know yeah it's almost better not to know
anything it is yeah just go read the
movie it's it's a thriller mystery it
does have horror elements it's it feels
like a horror movie it does kind of yeah
kind of like what was it seven more like
seven deadly sins or something like that
not gory but gory but it has some weird
you mean you're not sure which direction
the shit's gonna go you think it might
get pretty gory but it never does yeah I
just I saw the trailer and it just
looked like a well made movie and I kind
of that the premise was kind of
interesting so we rented it and I liked
it I don't care what the review said
well some of the review like one of the
reviewers that I saw
like he really liked it also but he like
did point out a couple things that
actually we kind of you know we're
talking about where we're watching yeah
there were easy ways you could have
gotten out of this conundrum but yeah
that's what I mean so there were a few I
will say outright that you know there
are a few things that kind of stretch
credulity a little bit or some character
motivations were a little bit murky and
I wasn't really sure about Mike he said
there were some situations that probably
could have been resolved like easily but
you wouldn't had a movie but on the
other hand I will say that I think this
movie as a thriller as a mystery was
successful because I was like invested
the whole time going what the [ __ ] is
going on with this situation and you
know what are these people's motivations
like what is this guy doing here what is
this that in the other so it did like
really keep you interested and keep you
guessing like the real thing real good
acting yeah and I will say I think this
is the only time that I've seen Simon
Pegg of Shaun of the Dead Fame also he
was Scotty in the JJ Abrams Star Trek
movies I think this might be the first
serious role that I've seen him in cuz
usually he did please like comedic roles
I knocked it out of the park man he's
the reason we play crap I didn't realize
he not only does he do like a really
really good like American accent like
you would never know that he was British
but also he's like kind of legit scary
and yes yeah we don't want to scare it
you know if you if you want to see the
movie go ahead check out now as well
we're gonna start spoiling so yeah I
mean I'm not gonna spoil all of it like
I said but the thing that I was going to
spoil they already spoiled it in the
trailer because we watched the trailer
and it kind of tells you what happens in
it and it happens like in the first 15
minutes so it's not like we're really
like ruining some big reveal she's she's
like a high-powered DEA she's the
district attorney yeah and her dad's
like [ __ ] trillionaire yeah he's like
I think it's like this super super
powerful family I think he's a banker I
think they reveal her younger brother is
like running for office like a senator
or something I think if mom was also
like a high paradis yeah so this is like
a very very you know well-connected very
rich very yeah family well he dies and
they all get their inheritances and she
gets hers and she only gets a million
dollars even though the rest of the
brother gets a 20 million and
and then the family lawyer says I don't
need to talk to you privately is there
some more [ __ ] your dad wanted you to
have and he gave her a letter it wasn't
it a letter it was like yeah it was like
a manila and yeah that had like it told
her to go [ __ ] the rest of her
inheritance is out in the backyard near
where her [ __ ] place at or something
used to be when she was a little kid you
know it's huge [ __ ] mansion and she
goes out there and she finds his damn
door and under the door that leads to in
like an underground bunker
yeah and in there's a [ __ ] dude
chained up to the wall but it's not in a
prison her dad's alive yeah yeah her
dad's been keeping this dude a prisoner
for [ __ ] lightning 27 years sir I
think he's at 30 years and no
instructions that's the thing about the
movie that I was like wait a minute hold
on if she if he tells her about the
[ __ ] prisoner then you would assume
that what he wanted was for her to
release him but she wasn't sure what to
do with him
and yeah that's the thing that's kind of
stuck basically like all that all that's
in this package that she gets like I
said she's kind of pissed because I
guess they don't like super super go
into it but there is like a lot of you
know a little bit of like implied
backstory that yeah you know because she
is kind of like she's not a prosecutor
she's you know a public attorney she's
district attorney which her dad I think
was always like really disappointed like
he thought it was really shameful also
he didn't like the guy she married he
didn't like like all these choices that
she made in her life
so it seemed like she was always kind of
trying to please him and the fact that
when they go to read the will because he
the dad dies like very very suddenly
like right at the very beginning of the
movie and that's supposedly a heart
attack and you know so no one is really
like prepared so they go to the reading
of the will and like everybody gets all
this like her brother her younger
brother gets like 20 million and stuff
and so she only gets a million and so
she was like sits this slap in the face
right and she was like really upset
about it she's like it's not so much the
money it's just the fact that you know
oh it's dad [ __ ] on me from beyond
the grave like again you know what I
mean so it's kind of like that but then
like the lawyer gives her the package
now the package has the key to the
bunker and it also has like a thumb
drive that has like a video of her dad
basically all her dad says in the video
he doesn't say
or nothing like that he just says this
is a secret that I think he says it must
stay buried I think is what he says like
on the video so which is in explicit
instructions and he says on there that
he doesn't want to give explicit
instructions in case somebody else opens
this or in case somebody else finds it
so he didn't want to say what it was
that's right he said it must stay buried
yeah that's why she didn't just let him
go yeah because maybe she also picked
that up I forgot that he said that yeah
that was like near the beginning it
didn't give any explicit instructions to
[ __ ] about what to do i what to do
with the dude man and that were really
it's hard to talk about the movie yeah
yeah really like say any more than that
because pretty much the rest of the
movie is kind of not it's not really
like a cat-and-mouse game I guess but
it's it's sort of like this unraveling
mission yet here he doesn't work if you
know what the deal is yeah where she
where her and this guy are like you know
talking about like all this stuff that
gets revealed like later on now like I
said you know Lily Collins plays you
know the the DA like the the main
character and she looks very very young
to be a district attorney I was there
that even though you know I read that
her character was actually supposed to
be 31 and that's how old she is too you
know which you know that is very young
for a district attorney in general but
she's not I guess she's not as young as
she looks she kind of has Winona Ryder
syndrome where she like kind of looks
like she said like a very very young
girl and it's like so it's kind of hard
to take her seriously but she's like an
older dramatic roles but she does a
really good job
like I said her character motivation is
kind of weird like sometimes I didn't
really know where she was coming from I
will say though that I was super
impressed with [ __ ] Simon Pegg in
this movie it's like I said this is the
only time I've ever seen him play an
American this is the only time I've ever
seen him play a role like this like a
very serious dramatic role he looks like
he lost a lot of weight for this role
because like I said he's been in a
bunker for 30 years because you know he
wasn't fat before but he was just you
know he's like a little bit of a stout
fella so he did actually like so he
looked like really lean and like kind of
taller than I was China he was working
out in a bunker - yeah yeah yeah and he
has like this really really long like
gray hair as you would if you were kind
of in prison for that amount of time and
just their interactions with
each other like as you know all of this
stuff about the past and all of a stuff
about who he is like starts to come out
you know so it really does get you
invested in the mystery even though like
I said you know that there might be some
plot holes there might be stuff that you
know is not entirely believable but I
was still invested enough in the
characters and invest enough in the
mystery interested enough to see where
this was gonna go like to kind of make
me not care about that right what was
that movie about the damn table that
went down through the prison the
platform yeah if you like the platform
you might like this movie yeah I mean
it's if you liked [ __ ] Silence of the
Lambs and that kind of [ __ ] you might
like to move yeah this is I mean it's a
pretty standard mystery thriller tight
you name a person Minzy yeah and I feel
like a lot of thrillers have kind of
elements that you know maybe a well know
that maybe it wouldn't happen like that
in real life
oh yeah you know what I mean that maybe
like you know some plot holes or
something like that yeah but honestly
this
I think this genre maybe you kind of
expect that yeah cuz this is the movies
playing and I'm talking to Jenny so well
why didn't he just do this yeah why
didn't you tell her why didn't he tell
you no well looking back on it now that
you know the whole [ __ ] story the
movie wouldn't [ __ ] happened well yet
it had and that's what I saw another
reviewer say that too because now in the
first video he did say secret has to say
berry - like I said he didn't tell her
what it was that doesn't mean but the
other reviewer made the point that he's
like well Eve if he didn't want anybody
to find this thumb drive and like you
know what was on it and he didn't want
anybody get suspicious then why didn't
he put another thumb drive in the bunker
that told her what to do right exactly
like he could have done that and I was
like oh yeah I guess he could have but
it's like you know what I mean it's it's
just little she's just like that yeah
it's just a movie and it's like I didn't
really think about that so much when I
was watching it because I was just like
I really liked the interplay between the
two of them and I really wanted to see
like you know what the [ __ ] he was doing
down there and Slade kind of reminded me
of silence and laughs because the dudes
kind of [ __ ] locked up and he scented
her out on missions to prove his story
he's telling there's kind of you know
you didn't that kind of like yeah
Hannibal Lecter type thing where he's
telling telling uh agent Starling you
know hey if you go over here you'll find
the head
you go over there you [ __ ] yeah that
kind of stuff going on well and there
was one scene in there in the bunker
like late in the movie that looked to me
like a direct homage to to silent to the
last you know I mean it looked like they
were directly I'm gonna try to evoke
that yeah feeling I having a real
dangerous prisoner you don't know you're
not sure yeah they were trying to do
that if it worked I thought the movie
was great it also kind of reminded me a
little bit of Cape Fear remember kids if
you like those movies you'd like this
one yeah so it's kind of like one of
those powerful family with secrets yeah
thing and you know somebody knows
somebody from the back coming back for
vengeance that kind of [ __ ] yeah so it's
that kind of thing so like I said as
long as you can overlook you know maybe
some potholes or why didn't they do this
why didn't they do that it's like just
don't think about it too much
yeah just enjoy the movie just enjoy the
movie it's a good like thriller acting
you know yeah like I said Simon Pegg is
easily the best part of this yeah you
know I was I was really impressed this
could change his career he's gonna be
able to do [ __ ] new roles after this
[ __ ]
maybe so like I said I'm not sure if
he's done dramatic roles previous to
this but almost like totally believe
this is the first one that I've seen him
in and I was like wow he could do a
really good American accent like I said
you wouldn't know he was British if you
were just like watching this and didn't
know yeah and he's like almost
unrecognizable like you know I mean like
with the hair and everything so and yeah
like I said he'd lost so much weight and
we did he did a [ __ ] performance of
his career if you ask me I think it was
just [ __ ] awesome yeah I thought he
was really great in this but yeah so
it's called inheritance like I said it's
very very new just came out a week or
two ago so if you're into thrillers and
[ __ ] like that then check it out
you